you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game Oh what to do let's try a
Sicilian chest de l99
first time playing all righty let's get
the night out fishing poles and strike
Queen c7 a knight b5 I could drop back
all right
um this fishing pole stuff I don't just
do in blitz or assuming bullet I do it
in blitz as well is interesting I'm
prepared to agam it upon f4 Knight g4 I
may still play or still hold off some
get d5 or b6 I've played with both if
I'm playing b5 black could try to open
up the position I have to keep in mind
that I'm behind in development so I
might take a more modest approach with
my deep on
more aggressive not so much with v6
uh-huh I can also hold off on all that
as well and consider and D 6 or even D 5
now I'm gonna go with D 6 a little bit
of a hmm
just holding off some let's get my
bishop here
I know his place I have not ruled this
out and now with the King here he's off
of this diagonal but at the same time
he's off he's still opposite my rook
these ideas spring to mind or even
half-open h-file so clearly I cannot
play b5 now let's go with v6 I need to
make sure I can meet f5 with E 5
I want my bishop here really soon uh
yeah let's get here
still have not give
up on IG for if the Queen goes here this
is that much more appealing c4 is
sensitive
I'm gonna keep my King in the center no
crime well I think it's best I push they
are threatening to take twice here
should I capture firsts mmm be my move
then
takes and then I get to push here with a
punch I wonder let scene you know even
on time important moment in the game
let's see Knight takes Knight Knight to
e5 I'm dropping this
okay let's take see how white recaptures
and then I'm pretty sure my fault move
is this to be concerned of the white
removing my night to key defender but I
do have my bishop here to defend d5 okay
necessarily have to play e5 year
what's wrong with Knight to g4 right now
I dropped g7 but maybe that's okay can
they try for that stuff oh they are oh
good grief there on this pawn I totally
missed that oh I missed that they're
going to be winning the b-pawn
not cool I did not see that okay well
maybe I have to do this to defend I
don't know why that was pretty basic I
should not have captured on d4 I didn't
see this attack against b6
yupper now I'm very weakened over here
my ID with rook to b8 is to exchange
Queens on v6 and then have this as a
follow up idea and get the piece back so
let's see small pawn Center but this is
really weakened can they make use of g6
it means to be seen not giving up on
this let's see what chest dale comes up
with gonna enter an endgame queenless i
mean now you're probably consider this a
middle game now so usually the pressure
against b6 can be met not usually but a
maneuver that is quite common is a
knight Knight jump to d7 now and these
moves I have rook to b7 the bishop tries
to cash out I could take here so we're
coming out of this what what's the story
here
even material but pretty pretty big and
balanced with this pawn structure this
is probably really painful nice move
yeah King is the best defender let's go
with this I'm on the b2 pawn
fortunately they cannot pile away with
the bishop a d6 okay probably this let's
uh increase some pressure against their
Queen side even on the clock
ideally I want to have my pawns on light
squares to restrict this guy so if I
could get in d5 Bishop d6 I think I'd
like that also d5 allows some lateral
defense of e6 now should I do that right
now d5 or rook here I'm tempted to play
rook to c3 let's do that just not even
allow that guy to go anywhere and with
this probably challenge my rook but then
I have this
let's have my rook defend she no fancy
stuff with taking advantage of pins have
that under control that move I didn't
see I could play here though
probably should that night will be too
too much of a bother
I could look to double up and this is uh
there's something difficult to defend
now I'm pretty sure for white are they
gonna pick up my H pawn should I say
them now let's go in for that I want to
track down the C pawn rook to e2 is not
a defense I'm threatening this and this
right now with my last move they could
grab the H Vaughn yeah so now I could
take here
I guess they missed this idea that rook
is in fact unprotected on c1 so let's
grab that they still have back rank
issues I have a better King position
okay and now probably just get right
back over here intensifying the pressure
against c4 these are ways to improve if
I get my pawn up to e for that Bishop
would actually be trapped
rook here I could take I have this
covered
so
if I go here I'm getting in the way
let's just lock down a little bit on the
king position okay now we improve the
king still tethered to the defense is
white of the c4 pawn I could play g5 or
just negate the rook kill it's a
influence along the fourth rank and now
I could probably start to expand and
then here next yeah well it's just March
could take here I think mmm let's go
with this let's keep a watchful eye over
the clock there's c4 hmm let's do this
and then improve my king no mates all
right let's get back here crash through
it c2 one rook off and then there's
definitely not going to be any fancy
mating Nets
all right let's save him now
and keep pushing with these guys got a
lot of squares covered probably even
take that Bishop let's attack the rook
15 seconds let's keep pushing
and we're going to be pushing through
soon can't take advantage of the pin I
promote
they're playing very fast just going to
trade down and win the King and pawn
ending and no stalemates
no stalemates and there we go mmm
dodged a bullet on that one for sure
okay yeah definitely dodged a bullet
let's go into the analysis now I don't
know I just overlooked Queen takes d4
and this piling up on b3 or b6 maybe in
the end rook here was a defense hmm
seems shaky to say the least
all right so there's analysis already
running let's go through it h5 don't
know if I would play this in over the
board
but uh yeah had success in both the
bullet and blitz this idea six in d6
structure I think that's fine I think
this is fine this is fine so this is
really where I needed an adjustment I'm
fine with keeping my king in the center
I should I should be going with this and
then I wonder what would be best for
white maybe maintaining another piece on
board
this I feel like I don't have any issues
with I'd be taking I'd be taking with
the bishop and I could even
look forward to Queen b7 as an example
Bishop to g5 I could go Queen here
if there's one square I need to to keep
a very close eye on it's d5 this is a
hole in my position and you know if
they're taking up my night I want to be
able to do what in the end I want to be
able to make sure this hole is uh I want
to make sure that a a pawn is there you
know I don't not fearing a pawn as much
as I would be a piece so I should be
playing e5 here and I could have saved
myself so much more time as well if I
would have just seen oh well Knight
takes Knight Queen takes I have to
defend that now so I should just go in
for this and whether or not Knight takes
Knight in this position is best hmm I
don't know maybe a knight here I have to
do this yeah with a 4 in there I have
this V 4 square to fight for control
over d5 that's probably something close
to equal here this may look a little bit
odd but I mean I'm not Castle down the
Kings side and it's linked in some way
there is some still idea I know it
didn't happen in the game but at some
point Knight g4 can hit and if white is
too soon what I've right now about
positions like this is that if white is
too soon with saying you know what let's
get a flight Square and go with h3 then
this H 4 you could see a knight slipping
into g3 you know Landing with forks and
who knows what more but yeah I should be
playing e5 here I wonder I wonder if it
was still okay but it seems extra scary
though because I'm throwing no thread at
white yeah they should probably keep
Queens on the board and this is spending
I think I'm quite alright with I mean if
I'm not getting mated that sounds a bit
extreme but if I'm not getting mated and
I'm not going to get made it here
think I'm just better because well one
of the things I'm looking into is not
this in as much as a better King
position my King is already in the
center and he he still has a ways to go
and well I do have I do have a passed
pawn as well and this this these are the
two key factors I see the the center
ponds and my king being a little bit
closer to the center or so well I should
probably come up with something
different than Queen takes pawn I think
the decision to take here was quite all
right I don't know I think I'm better in
this ending was there maybe some other
fancy tactic missed right around here
not so sure maybe no I was gonna say
this move but you know if they try to
lock down on this I can take and then
challenge the bishop I don't know let's
see what the computer has to say huh
okay well where was the your fight was
better up until what point yeah up into
the point where they you know the
decision to capture with the Queen let's
put the arrows on over there so it likes
white let's go to the beginning for a
moment hmm h5 is never gonna be a top
choice by the computer got d6 wants to
go in faster for f5 bishop there and
this move I'm prepared to play well if
my bishop is still on c8 I have this
move that's worth noting this pressure
white is not threatening in this
position to take on e6 for as long as
he's still home
so a for b6 uh-huh okay okay okay after
b6 then there's this with Bishop f3
coming huh
yeah and I'm losing I'm losing control
of my Center control yeah this is a way
to break down my my position yeah b6 so
notice the suggestion now Bishop d7
instead and well I mean this is also
with the bishop on d6 I have that reply
of Knight to e5 in case of f5 I have 95
it's a very compact structure I mean
aside from the h5 move everything else
is pretty normal right small pawn Center
Knights on good squares Bishop
Bishop's and Knights there but yeah on
b6 they had this opportunity and then
I'm losing control
this position is opening up there's not
a great lead in development for white
but I'm losing control my knight has to
find a new home and this is not a good
structural shift what's happening right
now this is not good I do not want to be
playing with an isolated pawn here and I
guess what's wow this is just winning
Wow
c4 takes big trouble for me big big
trouble
oh I don't even want to look any further
it's really bad it's really really bad
so they had their opportunity here I
have to I fallen for this idea before ii
don't know with I don't know that I was
recording while I was playing such a
game but yeah playing b6 now when I
cannot capture with upon this is this is
pretty good with the Bishop f3 idea
mm-hmm missed opportunity for white from
here how's it looking for a moment it
popped up Knight takes Knight with rook
to b8 but best was this and Knight takes
Knight Bishop takes with this Bishop g5
Queen b7 yeah
Queen b7 Bishop d7 did pop up for a
second
second Queen to b7 Queenie - hmm still
tough fight
yeah it's open it's an open position but
I think I think I think I'm still quite
all right here no if I was white I would
be allowing this age 3 move why could
probably take some time out for that now
I even have an opportunity for this move
taking advantage of the unprotected
bishop that would be a killer huh okay
well I didn't grab the knight on c6 I
take their rook to b8 taking is fine and
it does not like to the capture on v6
not best Bishop e2 and maybe maybe
looking for this stuff no no keep Queens
on the board right
maybe that's the that's the big thing to
really draw some attention to who has
the more vulnerable King it's definitely
me don't have enough pawn anymore this
is a sensitive point I have to be
careful maybe even some sacrifices right
at some point well that that is if I
have to capture with my Jeep on on f6
but I have enough security over that but
the Queen's on when you have the safer
King White has the safer King I go for
this exchange and wants to go with
Bishop here
the difference being to inconvenience my
Wrexham
collaborator yeah that's a nice little
detail right Bishop takes Knight takes
to do this move first if you're gonna
get my Bishop you're gonna inconvenience
your up because basically what white is
saying and then yeah I have to develop
him again I'm not I'm not threatening
that pond still even is okay I mean
pulling for white some the immediate the
immediate capture I guess is level but
feels like it's much easier to play for
a black better King physician yeah guess
it has two different you have to defend
like that can I not get away with this
maybe
yeah I slowly start to pull ahead right
around this point expanding in the
center good king position and upon drops
and it's gone from here
okay well dodged a bullet there with the
b6 move that had their opportunity to
take on c6 and get their Bishop on this
dog you know it didn't happen
Queens were exchanged and left me off
the hook some okay well as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below and I will
catch you in the next one that's all for
now take care bye
you